well happy Monday to you and uh I just
want to say I thoroughly enjoyed the
Oscars for a number of reasons it how
was your weekend buddy my weekend was uh
was all about the Oscars just Sun so
just Sunday night was about the Oscars
when I think about the weekend sometimes
there can be an event where you don't
think about anything else but the Oscars
like wow yeah like you were nominated
for what I sure wasn't for sure hey hey
look at me right now relax on the Oscars
and we don't really I don't watch the
Oscars normally because I get I it's a
party I'm not invited to but I went over
to grillo's house and took it in you got
had an Oscar party nope it was just me
it was just the families it was just the
kids and the gorillas that was it around
the Oscars yeah so and um and then what
night did we oh that was Thursday night
we're both at the Laugh Factory my mom
came to town you know that's the first
time she's ever seen me do stand up I
heard John loveit's uh snubbed her I'm
gonna have to talk snubbed my mom what'
he do we grew up you know I grew up on a
Saturday Night Live kid that's that's my
history man Saturday Night Live so the
reason I'm into CU my mom every Saturday
night we'd watch Saturday Night Live
Like that's where I get all my [__] man
that's where I get my inspiration from
right John lovez obviously you know the
John LoveIt all right live John LZ he's
he's my buddy so I'm at the LA Factory
Brian's there there's a bunch of other
comedians there and uh I guess John litz
was walk in my mom goes oh my God and
and goes John I'm like your biggest fan
he goes okay yeah and just like snubs
and my mom goes my mom's feelings were
so hurt my mom told me I'm like John
loves to do that to you she yeah I'm
like okay and for the record John's not
like that so it's very surprising so I
I'll tell you what's surprising he is
like that he did it well well whatever
was going because I've had one encounter
with him and he is like that let's not
make excuses because who knows what and
I was actually defending John and my mom
like who knows what he's doing with but
you can't be you just can't do that yeah
but he is that guy like then that's what
happen you know what I'm saying so we
say he's not like that well because he
did do that and then this is what else
is shitty my mom told me that and I
didn't see him I'm see would want I
confront him like Hey man you're mean to
my mom SL no you beat up John but then I
was outside waiting for my car and I see
John and another guy goes John what are
you doing here man and he goes what the
[__] you think I'm doing here dead
serious I went oh really yep I know John
very well that's very strange you don't
know him that well I know him pretty
I've known him for many many years
that's very strange i' I've seen him be
very much the opposite all the time so
that's I wonder what was going on cuz I
I had a long talk with him that night he
seemed like he was in a good mood to you
no I'm just telling you that I i' I've
seen him behave in the exact opposite so
it's very out of character I guess it's
a better way to put it very out of
character for him can't give people a
pass you got to own it cuz that's him
you know what I'm saying like there's no
passes should call he did that he did
that so that I've never done that ever
in my life I've never seen you do that
that's not our protocol right that we've
never done that so so there's no one out
there going Brian did that to me that's
never happened no one going Brendan did
that to me that's never happened that's
not my thing so if you do if I've seen
you do that in that small window yeah I
promise you it's not the first time he's
done I know you know him on set and
stuff like can we get him on and have
him call your mom uh yeah I'm I'm I
don't hold any grudge against him he's a
funny guy he gave me years of
entertainment so I'm going to give him a
pass got a but I will take a fat Brown
hand to his fat face he wants to do the
podcast so I say like a shave Geral I'd
love to have him on that we're going to
get that F we're going to get him on
we're going to call him a shave dribble
and we're gonna and we're going to make
him you know what he was so he look like
a heirless hedgehog he was so funny to
me cuz he I did my my bit and he came on
and he goes I do this bit about a
binocular and an Englishman and he goes
I have a binocular and an Englishman bit
too and mine goes like this and he
starts doing mine word for word and I go
that's my bit and he goes well I wrote
one too so I don't know what you want to
do this is going to be awkward no he's
hilarious he's so funny how about but
how about that's the first time my mom
seen me do stand up was that the last
fact dude and you from what I understand
did very well yeah I mean as in best
you've ever done right yeah I mean we're
changing stuff up packed house packed
house house Friday night and so what
your mom say about your standup not much
I know you listen this mom not much I
love it I love your mom I love your mom
and I love Aunt nuby yeah well I think
sometimes parents get very nervous my
father for years had would when he would
come to stand up which was very rarely
he would uh I need attention uh no
wonder I'm a comic uh but when he would
come to my standup I swear to you on my
life he would stare and he wouldn't
laugh even a little and I would see him
turn to my mom and say what do he say
because he couldn't hear and I said
what's he doing and my mother's like
he's too nervous to enjoy it and then
one day after I'd been a pro he showed
up I had all my family there my extended
family cousins in New York I got up and
did stand up and I for about 45 minutes
and I did destroyed one of the best
comic sets I've ever had and and I for
the first time in my life and I was
probably 38 39 first time in my nope
first time in my life I made my dad howl
and I kept seeing him he would laugh and
put his hands in his face because he
couldn't believe it and that was a it
sounds weird but that was a marker for
me that was a seminal moment in my life
because you know your father's an
important figure in your life and get
that kind of approval he I I guess what
what what it meant was hey I'm not a
jackass I'm a professional
you know I I do this for I hear you I I
don't look at it that way like I could
and I'm not I know they listen to the
podcast and I'm not being mean I give
two shits whether they laugh at my St or
not it's really not for it's not for
them my dad never missed a football game
never missed a fight flew to Brazil all
over the Big 12 all over all over the
nation for football Super so you know so
they're he you know I have his approval
I I don't look for his approval in ComEd
I look for ideas I don't give a [__]
he's laughing I that sounds weird but
he's never he's never seen he came to
our Denver show it's a little different
but yeah well he he would kept saying
like he was watching all the people line
up to take pictures with you and he just
said this is unbelievable like he's you
know well when when we when he was out
here [__] last week we're going down
Venice he wanted to get oh I found this
new fish and chips place by the way
which the English part of me you know
obviously digs it I up they there's some
new fish and chips place it's off
of it doesn't matter I say no it does
Manchester R Venice bwock and manchest
some they're they're known for it said
you got me it said
awardwinning fries it said fries and it
was my cheat me I'm like [__] so
interesting you say that when it said
awardwinning I'm like God damn and it
showed like the awards I'm like I got to
try the fries yep and I was walking my
son at my son all day so he was asleep
I'm like well I might as well try him
now I'll do my cheat meal now while he's
sleeping got the fish and chips got that
and uh I don't know where I was going
the story but it was it was delici were
they were they awardwinning that's the
question they definitely were see cuz
that works on me it does work when you
see a certain when when a when a like
best coffee in the world award-winning
coffee if I see that it's sign tip I
know what like most like classy
restaurants don't show the awards they W
remember that Steakhouse we went to oh
it said best voted best in the midwest
or some [__] in country terrible it was
terrible most most places like
intelligencia in Phils name any coffee
shop uh groundworks which I'm addict to
right now they're almond latte I just
can't get enough anyways none of them
have Awards on like voted best in vanice
there's none of that cuz the product
speaks for themselves so usually when
you see voted best but this fish and
chips my word so my word is right my
word wow I don't where I don't forget
where I was going with that story well
cuz you got suckered into the how they
advertised for the fish and chips
awardwinning yeah it's very strange a
sign can make a big difference for me
like if I see a restaurant and there's a
chalkboard and they've written out the
menu in chalk and it's a cool color
and I look in there and there are clean
lines I mean Decor can make a [__]
difference to me if I see that the owner
created um an aesthetic in the room that
that jives with my that resonates with
me usually I can guess the food's going
to be oh I know where I was going with
this I know I figur cuz I was walking
down Venice with my dad and you know I'm
not [__] Tom Cruz people were like
hey shut big brown and taking pictures
and my dad goes how do you know him I'm
like I don't and we kept going my dad's
I know I'm like Dad if you ask me that
every I don't know these people they
they listen to the podcast or they went
to a comedy show I don't like that I
don't know them yeah you're you're kind
of famous not famous in the least with
I'm just saying when like I don't know
them I don't know he keep going how do
you know them how do you so and I forgot
to tell you the story what so for my
son's birthday I bought him that car I
post on Instagram that big ass truck
yeah it came in 1,000 pieces at least
from China with Chinese instructions
yeah I'm like [__] I get out
like can be a beast so I put a headband
on so my hair doesn't get my eyes like a
man sleeve a shirt on I'm doing work
Papa sh Papa shab's like let me get my
hands wet let me get in
there you know you know when you realize
my dad listen to podcast you know you
know when you like when I was young like
whenever we need something done like if
I can fix it like we I should make
models all the time as a kid my dad like
let me you do it you know and you like
damn there it is but you didn't know the
difference like he might have had
[__] glue all over his hands I'm like
why is that on the pieces
he something up well now as a dude he
would put together I'm like but he's my
dad so I want to be respectful and I
would see him doing it wrong doing it
wrong and then he'd put together I'm
like can I see it now and he be like
yeah I mean I guess we have to put down
I was going to do that but I'm like all
right cool I could have got it done
probably in 45 minutes so you had to you
had to undo the damage and damage andedo
it if pop shot wasn't there I would have
got done like I said 45 minutes took
about three hours so and we were both
drenched and stat
well that thing finally it was a giant
truck that the kid's not gonna be able
to drive until he's seven but it's a
remote control so I so I drive him in it
that's hilarious it's great it's great
well I um my wife wanted me to put
together a bed just a bed not a truck
just a bed slats pretty standard SL yeah
slats and then like posts and you know
couple screws and I looked at it I
looked at it and there no way you're
doing dude it was all it was it was it
was a lot of pieces to me and most
people would do it and I went I looked I
go ah I can't do that cuz I have no
energy I can't might have no energy
suddenly in my arms are legs I suddenly
had I suddenly having trouble standing I
had to sit down I was like ah where' all
my energy go well I do have the energy
to dial a couple of my boys who are out
of work actors but happen to be you know
dude the rich privileged white card I'll
pay you $200 to put this [__] bed
together like we'll be right over y
meanwhile they're putting together my
wife's up there supervising and I I had
to get I had to go work out oh my I was
exhausted see I I like that like when
that came I was like check it out like
here we go here time to put the dad hat
on yo little dude you want to see this
I'm doing it yeah I do work like he had
a whole he had he had a uh like a tool
set they bought him it's like a little
area you put that bad boy together I
mean I feel like a proud pop one put
together he didn't know [__] as the
difference like he doesn't know but it
makes you feel good if you had a gun in
my head and you said Brian fix that
drawer we got a drawer little drawer
problem you had a gun in my head he said
but you can go to Home Depot and get all
the stuff you come back here you'd have
to pull the trick do it yeah I that way
I don't know how you didn't grow up
though you grew up with r rich kid rich
kid you see I have to get [__] done but
the thing that's right that's when you
know privileg
yeah
man if there there's no there's no
bigger way to turn a girl off if like
you have flat tire like oh my God who
should we call oh boy you [__] oh yeah
you call you you're like I got no idea
what that's the one thing I did learn
how to do once that change oil because
of that can you change oil um 100% no h
no no but what about about like lights
and stuff in the house like the the fuse
box and stuff like that 100% no 100% no
you just never learn you didn't have to
the worst I I'm trying to think of
anything I've ever even tried to do I I
can't I can fix my coffee machine sort
of yeah because I need coffee no no I'm
I'm a disaster and I panic I have a
mental block I'll run away oh my god oh
I have to sh the story I can't even hang
a picture properly oh you got to find a
stud girls are drying up right now
anyways there I have to tell this
story I'm at Brian's house I'm at
Brian's house working we're working on
my stamp together writing stuff out for
future [__] and my car is parked on the
street where it uh it says sweep uh
cleaning or whatever you can't park
there Street yeah street sweeping so his
wife goes uh his neighbor knocks the
door like uh you need to move the
Bentley over there they're they're going
to tow it it's going to take it me and
Brian are just in the middle of this I'm
like well [__] man I never you know this
J I never let anyone drive my car ever
how do we let Val let me let me just add
a caveat to what you said too because we
were in the middle of work and the
ticket my wife goes ticket is 70 bucks
and brenon goes H I don't think I have
the energy to go out there and move it
70 bucks might be worth it right now
because I've got to get this done true
so and I was like I understand that I
understand saying that I'm GNA have to
spend $7 to get my work done that's
literally cost to doing business that's
that's what I thought like shipping
hand and by the way just so you know his
friend Jimmy Burke goes I'll move it y
I'll move it the guy who looks like he
has he has chemo and by the way also
lives in New York and never drives Drive
doesn't own a car it's 55 years old
nothing and I'm like how you just move
it from there to there
not not it's a neighborhood what damage
can you do literally car comes back and
goes sits down like whatever me and
Brian finished our work we make some
stupid unicorn video that was funny I go
out to my car he parked like down the
street The Neighbor comes out
goes hopefully that family member friend
move your car I'm like excuse me he goes
ah he did he did some damage on the curb
there
like um H goes look your look at your
wheel you look at it the
SC the scrape of all scrapes my
went God I was so mad I was so mad I how
much will that cost you to fix uh a
couple hundo the guy's fixing right now
but not not just a couple hyundo yeah I
don't have to replace the rim if you
would have okay like hit it hard enough
where the rim was like crooked it would
have cost you then I got buy a new rim
and then I would have to build Brian
Callen cuz that would be $1,000 right
yeah at least yeah for that would be
tough would be tough they just don't
have them it be a beast to get you have
to order it yeah it' be a nightmare
anyways but it's a scratch and they can
just guys fix it right now I dude I was
like oh my God and I saw you guys cuz
you guys were leaving I was leaving too
and I was I didn't want to pull up next
to you because I didn't want you to see
how mad I was so I just sat in my car I
was like it's my fault why would I let
that guy drive it it's not my it's it's
on me man I I was going to tell cuz if I
told him freak out tell yeah I know I
didn't want you to tell him feel it's
fine I know he didn't mean to obviously
it's my fault for letting anyone else
drive my car it's getting fixed now I
was all the energy I didn't say anything
to you the night at the com is that car
the kind of car that is prone to that
because of the way it's positioned not
at all not at all it doesn't have to
drive not at all you any car if you
Scuff the rim on the side of the curb
it's going to [__] it upe when they're
black yeah don't hit don't hit the curb
never I've never hit a curb why does the
driver have to be black no the rims are
the rims are black yeah so he didn't
actually tell you you had to find out
through the neighbor he doesn't know
cars I think he just thought oh whatever
it's he doesn't know he's also not in
the cars I guar if it was someone who
knew and he doesn't know what that car
is I promise you no he has no idea he
has no idea what a Tesla is nothing he
doesn't he's so non-materialistic I've
never met anybody less materialistic no
I got over it yeah yeah it's fixed now
well there it is yeah it pretty
frustrating and then uh yeah what can
you do you realize if I was younger I'd
been blood red mad I was mad for the
initial mad and then five minutes
driving down the road I'm like I'll
figure it out well it's all perspective
you put it everything in perspective
it's also my fault like why in the world
would I let him park my car why would I
do that the thing about a Bentley like
that is if you get in an accident and
they dent in the whole hood and all that
right like they you know they they do
let's say they do $5,000 $10,000 worth
yeah Insurance yeah insurance but but
does that um because it's such a piece
of jewelry does that affect the overall
value of the car when you go to sell it
oh 100% you have disclose that kind
right because because that they such a
liability in that sense right because
it's such a work of art that I guess
you'd have to go to benley they'd have
to literally replace all the parts yeah
and I mean imagine having like a uh like
a ferari Daytona 64 Ferrari Daytona and
you [__] that I mean it's like it's a
piece of jewelry it's over game over a
million dollar car like there's not you
you can repair it but it's going to [__]
the car's value up so bad you literally
just if you're in if you're B that balls
like it's the ultimate car like Daytona
is the best car of all time I think if
you in there I mean you can't get one
for under a million probably maybe three
million now I think Jay Leno has one
maybe Seinfield I don't know you you
rarely see them they're like the perfect
car if you wreck that thing I I feel
like you just be like you just feel like
crying I don't I don't it's such a piece
of jewelry it's such a work of art oh my
God I think that your car I'm not even
in the cars but that super sport is
pretty pretty amazing as far as looking
wise yeah just I love cars man you do
that's an irrational love I never I
never sweat people for loving cars like
I don't call them materialistic it's a
passion that people have and like Rogan
Rogan will talk to you for hours about
cars he loves cars me about cars then
Rogan he uh he knows more about like old
school cars hot rods and stuff oh he
does newer cars Porsche he knows a lot
about right me me and him both know a
lot about Porsche J Shaw beats both of
us in Porsche really oh yeah we grew up
Porsches yeah yeah best car probably I
think best car ever all time um as far
as like overall brand everyone's like
what the [__] are we talking about uh
speaking of fancy things when we get to
your Oscars did you see the Rolex
commercial last night Oscars sure did I
sure did and in the sky like this yes I
like I swear to youn it's so interesting
you said that because when you talked
about award-winning fish and chips I'm
going to tell you something right now
and you know I'm I don't give a [__]
about watches I saw that commercial it
made me want to buy a Rolex right how
about that watch it got to me it got to
me because it's a piece of history and I
it was it was an amazing commercial an
amazing commercial how good was that and
then when they showed Jim Carrey with
the Rolex I was like what the [__] I
just think interesting that all the
commercials are becoming political too
Cadillac oh that play that hey real
quick and then we'll get off this that
fish and chips place is called the we
chippy Gourmet fresh handcut fries man I
want some now the we chippy is that on
Yelp that you're looking at no I took a
picture it cod cod fried cod fresh fried
cod and then the potatoes they're they
you see them cutting them yeah bro yep
[__] you then they got a little uh uh
tun next to it a tun place next to him
they got uh a tuna bowl a poke ball poke
bow next to it award- winning across the
street from them that's how I found I
stumbled upon them yeah the ground Works
uh all they want too they want that's in
that same same Circle they want with
some bums and some other [__] look at
that 4 and A2 out of what was that
that's four and a half out of five son
that's good that's good all you go the
only keep me coming here every day is
the parking all right well look at that
they look good you know what that looks
delicious my mouth is water and it's in
it's served in newspaper as well it
should be the we chippy shout out
parsley funny how a little parsley Dashi
dash of hold on bro they're fries they
have 20 different flavors you can choose
from God damn it and sauces and a frosty
root beer ah [__] you I'm going to punch
somebody in the face right now a frosty
root beer sock me in the dick cuz I that
but that Rolex commercial was so good
right it was listen so well done they
just showed overtime like how classic
Rox is and like all the movie stars
wearing them dude I don't watch the
Oscars are so like you realize how
beautiful movies are and you realize
like with those like the power of
imagery and and how and the woman said
something that was really interesting
you know and I think one of the yeah one
of the things one of the values of Art
uh maybe the biggest value is that it
reminds you that we all laugh and cry at
the same things um you know we all sort
of cry at the loss of a loved one we
loss we cry at a breakup we laugh when
somebody thinks they're really cool and
they fall and make an ass to themselves
there are a lot of lot last night you're
saying yeah well that that was there a
lot of people were talking about how art
and great story and great movies bring
people together and it's true they're
human stories and and that's that to me
is the value of
some of relax for sure no but I mean
this is an important thing to talk about
because that's kind of the value of
anytime artistic expression it's kind of
the Cornerstone of every culture right
like cultures Define themselves on their
artistic expression a lot of times dance
music you know and I do think that it
draws a through line through it like it
makes us all remember we're human beings
you know but did you like the Oscars I
love them yeah I love them and how many
movies did you see that were on there I
absolutely none okay but it doesn't
matter I I I loved I loved the I love
the whole spectacle I like the emotion
involved what you think of Jimmy Kim as
a host I thought he was taking some heat
personally I thought he was amazing
personally I thought I thought he was
good he's taking heat because uh
remember the the black guy who won the
award the first Muslim to win an Oscar
the black for moonlight you know that
guy and he goes he's making anyone with
a different name usually people of color
he was making fun of their names and he
goes what's your son's name and he said
something he goes well that you know
he's fun of their names so a lot of
people super people are so uh uptight I
think he was great I thought he was good
I thought I thought the candy from the
sky was super cheesy I don't I didn't
even care about that I just thought he
was funny as [__] I I think Jimmy
Kimmel's so easy like it's just easy for
him not trying yeah he's not trying he's
just he's a good MC man you know I mean
and he doesn't even make it about
himself it's just easy for him that's a
tough job when everybody's looking at
you and people try too hard Chris Rock
did it last year right uh the year
before I thought no Chris Rock did last
year because remember he had to do the
whole monologue about no black people
being up for an award yes and before
that it was two actors uh the woman
what's her name is someone else Tina Fay
and uh Amy po did it for a while uh no
who is it though there was one that
wasn't can you bring that up chin but
and then there was also um uh didn't
Rich Richie uh Richard uh who's the
cedan gas Rich Richie Rick Ricky Ricky
gar he did it for a while yeah he was
really good he's brilliant very good so
Neil was
2015 in
2016 there they Hadis rock that was last
year and who was who was before Neil the
two
girls Ellen degenerous who who then who
hosted you remember when Tina Fay and uh
Emy po hosted God it's amazing how Seth
MF 2013 maybe I'm thinking of the
Academy Awards or I'm thinking of the
golden glob I'm think Golden Globes yeah
time flies damn Seth McFarland Billy
Crystal I thought I I loved I loved that
Jimmy Kimmel I thought I thought it was
good when you see the Oscars you realize
how big of a deal it is you know what
I'm saying like everyone who's won is
such a big deal how about this I got
some I got droing knowledge for your old
ass I got one for you how much do you
think the Oscar award's worth the Oscar
awards how much are the no just the the
if you win one how much do you think
that's worth well I believe it is it
does have it's goldplated I believe mm
24 Karat plated and it's copper
underneath so what do I think it's worth
as far as if you were to melt the gold
down hey man godamn it how much do they
pay for that award like there's a bunch
of them they have to pay per award make
this easier sir like how much they have
to pay for the actual statue um for like
for each person like if I gave you these
shoes this pair of Jordan for or the one
I'd say 300 bucks 400 400 close 400
now uh Michael Jackson bought I he
forget I think the gone with the win the
whoever won that one he bought for like
1.6 million they have a contract how
interest this the Oscars have a contract
where you cannot sell them there's no so
like if you go to Black Market you have
to offer it to the academy first and
they can buy it for one cent if they
deny it then you can sell so no one can
you can't put them out like it's illegal
to sell them does that make sense like
you you'll be banned for life if you
sell your award that's the rule but like
you can sell Golden Globe you can sell
an Emmy but you cannot sell an Oscar is
that do that though what's the reason
for that I know it makes it more I think
I think they on your shelf I think it's
more I think I think it makes it way
more cool yeah there's a sanctity to it
or something it is every actor it is the
biggest award you can ever have another
one um so when an actor actress wins an
award uh uh usually their career their
minimum goes way up skyrockets right
when Hal Berry won for I think monsters
ball didn't she won monsters ball her
minimum I think was uh 300 or 600,000
per movie after showing the award it
went all the way up to six million per
movie I believe it they were showing the
averages of people's career she's still
so [__] beautiful smoking so after an
Oscar this shows you the minimum like
you the the man you can get yes yeah I I
thought it was I also thought what I
thought was really interesting about the
Oscars was how in a lot of ways it feels
like Donald Trump is becoming a great
unifier among a lot of I went to say
have I can't think of a more time I
can't think of any time since I've been
alive you know whatever 33 years when
more people are more together now
because of trump so he's I know he's
terrible in office and everyone hates
him blah BL a lot of people like him but
yeah yeah but in the or actually a lot
of people approve of his agenda but they
disapprove of him yeah but can I can't
think of anytime America was closer
together like people like sticking
together now like you see that room and
you see everyone and they're being
eloquent about it you know Frank was
saying that Frank really was like I'm
telling you dude it it feels like this
guy is going to be the biggest
galvanizing Force because what happens
is Americans of all ilks have a deep
sense of fair play and we all inherently
know that this is the place where all
are welcome regardless right you just
well as soon as you say to Americans I
don't care a lot I don't care who they
are if you say you can't come to this
country because of your beliefs all of
us go yeah wait a minute wait a minute
that's messed up we all go cuz we don't
like a sense of of uh this is what
people fought and died for it's a
country of Li see the guy won the award
that didn't show up because of that yeah
and he's from Iran he's I'm not I
thought that was very powerful it was
very eloquent too so a lot of these a
lot there's seems to be like this silent
unifying protest or just people have to
say like when that Mexican actor said
we're migrant workers we travel all over
the world and that is true when it comes
to actors and he said and as a migrant
worker and as a Mexican and as a human
being I am opposed to any kind of a wall
that divides people very powerful you
know it doesn't mean that subject you
see khabib's uh father and Coach got
turned they're not they can't they're
not allowed in we'll wait for that
current event they're not allowed in he
fights this week well there you go
another guy that I uh this kid is trying
to be an amateur boxer that I spar with
sometimes a young kid in my in gym that
I go to his dad has been in this country
he's from uh he's English he's been in
this country for 20 years he got
deported yesterday damn yeah he got
deported after 20 years cuz he's illegal
now he's illegal but I thought I thought
you only get sent if you have like a a
rap sheet like if you have a felon or
something like that well in his case he
didn't but in his case he was working
and for whatever reason pulled they
showed up and they said you are out so
what yeah it's very sad in la la yes and
he had time to pack a bag and leave this
kid uh um hold on so cops are coming to
people's houses I believe there was some
kind I believe there was some kind of
well this was the case I believe there
was some kind of a raid or something at
his workplace but either way he was
deported um because he was working for a
the governor the governor of California
was like we're we're not going to after
people yeah we're not doing that here
yeah well this guy
I yeah I don't know if his dad was in
this state I don't have the whole story
but I know that he was really bummed and
his dad got the yeah because they they
not but they're not seeking out legal
his dad got deported after yeah yeah but
you made it sound like they sought him
out cuz he doesn't have a green card and
then shipped him like they're going door
to door well no I don't know that's not
happen in California no no but but but
in if if you are sometimes if you are
working in a place and somebody else is
being you know uh has a criminal record
and they check everybody's you know
status that's I I don't I have to get
the exact story but I know he's been
here for 20 because I know the the legal
yeah state by state it's rules like
California can't do that they're not
going house to house and if you don't
have a green car you're getting deported
yeah I know that's not I know that for a
fact right yeah yeah no they're not
knocking on doors unless you're but if
you have if you have AAL a felony and if
you have a felony get pulled over they
are they're still not seeking but even
if you have a mild infraction nowadays
apparently La not not in California
though the governor came out was like
we're not Jerry Brown yeah but the but
the federal government can always in a
in a it yeah yeah so I if ice comes in
if if if customs and immigration come in
have a rap sheet well well they can they
can technically they can technically
deport anybody illegal right they can
technically deport anybody yeah the
point of the story is though you need
more details they're not going house to
house in California they that's not
happening he you're missing a huge
component there but it just is amazing
that he he was really depressed cuz his
dad has been here for 20 years has a job
has a life has a wife or you know not a
wife but a girlfriend I mean he's got a
life here and he cannot come back it
it's crazy you know another guy I know
another guy is dating a woman who's uh
is illegal she's now uh for whatever
reason she's now been put on notice
because she had to check in with her so
what's going on with a lot of these
people from what I have read is they
have to check in they when you're
illegal for there there was sort of a
program where you would check in with an
immigration officer periodically right
and because you were working here and
you were paying taxes now when you do
that they now they're monitoring you now
saying to you look there's a chance you
may be deported regardless that is that
is a chance and so you know they worry
about going back to work they worry
about going to check because you could
go check with your Customs guy and he
could say you got to get out of here
that's scary anyway look I mean it's a
it's a contentious issue it's illegal
immigrants I understand there's there's
two sides I'm staying out of that for
now but it was pretty interesting but we
got on a different subject here um what
I was going to say what I was going to
say is the Oscars and I just think it's
really interesting that in a lot of ways
regardless of where you stand on the
Trump issue or whatever it is in a way
bringing out for me it sounds like a
generous side of people and and the best
people closer yeah it's also bringing
out a sense of people are voicing their
idea of what they think is fair and fair
play you know I think that's important
and that's it's pretty I thought the
Oscar were great though man I thought
Timberlake was good didn't like his
haircut I watched the pre stuff for the
fashion I'm super into the fashion
drives me nuts when guys were just black
tux you are an amazing you're amazing
how in fashion you are you're the you
showed up in camo sweats and some
strange vest at my house and I was like
well there it is strange I came from
working out you look like a giant Canary
and I mean know you look like one of
those tropical you know you look like a
tropical bird one of those very tropical
colorful birds I appreciate it y tou can
something like that my friend you were
very colorful I'll just say that and you
look like you blend it in with the
foliage from the waist how about on the
the Oscars I thought uh I wish you know
how when they show their faces I wish
people showed their true emotions that's
what I don't like because it's so hard
to win an Oscar the timeing the project
has to be right the timing has to be
right the chances of you being back
again are not [__] good so when they
show people's face and the other guy win
they're all mhm I wish they would
actually show me like [__] that's what I
I'd be like [__] not that I'm not glad
that iy didn't win but [__] man I needed
this this is a big deal like Mel Gibson
did it you see Mel Gibson when Mel
Gibson he goes look at he go like that's
I want some legit emotion out of you I
guarantee you if you had a little
[__] speaker so we could hear what
they're thinking when someone else wins
it's all ah [__] well Patty Jenkins said
unbelievable Patty said when her when
when her actress St Charlie Throne won
for the movie monster and uh Patty said
I said what was it like afterwards and
she goes it's good but the party we got
to remember that four other people
people five other people lost and their
whole team is there and so it's not like
I
like get out of my party I'm saying
though there's a lot you're like that
your table's like that and then the
other tables and stuff are you know it's
a little bit more somber it's not as
like woohoo as you think because people
lost so sometimes I guess it depends
because I would be going nuts I wouldn't
give a [__] about the other people yeah
but you yeah but you might work with
those people and that's not how
Hollywood works you don't gloat
everybody's like we not gloat but you
want to celebrate like I wish they were
real when they show those things man
well like Ryan gosson was a okay you can
see he's like [__] have you seen
uh Faith Hill do that she actually did a
reaction like that it was for like a
country music award or something where
they they announced another winner and
she was like [__] see that's what I want
because it's a big deal never that when
the world's watching you [__] smile
and you clap that's fake though I don't
like fake no that's called putting on
good appearances sir when you got 200
million people watching or whatever it
is you don't go I'm not being no I'm not
saying being a sore loser I just be like
dang I'm not saying you're going [__]
you but I like damn that's embarrassing
too I that would that I would that would
be an embarrassing reaction for the
world to see you you let you're closest
friends see that or your relatives but
the idea that you would do that in front
of the world nah you you you in a
dignified way clap smile good for you
that's how you do it that's how I
disagree I wouldn't do it that way well
the good good luck good luck when they
blast you on every social media site and
every news media where they're just like
look at brenon shop sore loser over
there I mean not it's not see you're
taking it wrong it's I may be taking it
wrong but that's how the world would
take it I don't think so well if you're
just like damn it would not be good for
your standing in Hollywood or in the
world is it might make you real popular
though I agree yeah well not I wouldn't
be the first to try it I would I would
anyway when somebody wins over you they
win over you it's all good I mean it's
subjective too it's not like Casey
Affleck's a better actor than Denzel
Washington the committee thought
remember it's a committee yeah did you
like did you not like any speeches what
did you think of uh what's her names the
uh what is the black woman's name who
won for fences um she's brilliant yeah I
liked it everybody thought it was cheesy
when I was with and I was like I liked
her no she's great I think I think yeah
everyone's looking to make like a ground
shaking speech and start this revolution
it's
like you're actors let's relax a little
like everyone's trying to Davis is that
she was brilliant I thought she had the
best speech I likeed it but a lot of
people were like ah and I was like no
listen this is your one chance this
might be the only time in your life in
front of people that you get a chance to
speak this way right I I just like also
okay here's a really tough question I
just don't like it a one after the one
after the other one after the other
actors they all actors yeah it's like
relax you want an award this is their
chance this is their chance to to to act
can what do you think about this
difficult question question do you think
if it hadn't been that whole issue about
blacks winning do you think as many
black would do you think Moonlight do
you think Viola Davis do you think uh um
these various black actors and actresses
as great as they were would have won yes
you I do I think Moonlight and in those
actresses they were so damn good I think
this I think if the roles were reversed
where they announced Moonlight one but
then they're like oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
actually la la win it would been a way
bigger deal the black community would
have went freaked the [__] out but since
it was
backwards it's not a big deal I like the
Oscars because I think you know saying
black people been so mad where white
people like to me the the Oscars the
other thing that I find moving is the
Oscars are the least racial um gathering
in many ways that you can get in terms
of in terms of like true solidarity
among people and human beings last year
we beg the differ uh yeah and which
which is why I which is why I criticized
last year which I thought which why I
thought it was complete [__] that I
that I thought it was a complete
horeshit lie to suggest that Hollywood
is racist Hollywood goes out of its way
and this is a classic example and I
thought it was unfair I thought it was
[__] and I I thought it was totally
dishonest um and and so because I think
the Oscars are the exact opposite and
they celebrate not only black uh uh
artistic expression they they Muslim
Iranian artistic expression they
celebrate F worldwide expression the the
the again what I was saying is that art
artistic it's Artistic Endeavors and
it's it's it brings people together
because it's based on how well you make
people laugh and cry and that's what I
[__] love about dude good for Emma
Stone winning huh another level you went
a Oscar at her age on just another level
um yeah so none of you guys saw those
movies right I've seen most of them
outstanding so you saw La La Land uh saw
La La Land uh didn't see Manchester by
the sea I heard it's kind of sad I
usually don't get down sad movies yeah
look saw
fences I saw uh The Jungle Book
obviously um what else one oh I saw
hacksaw Ridge I thought it was all right
I saw h i saw the Jungle Book which I
[__] loved what do you think of
Hacksaw Ridge it was all
right good
story I thought if M Gibson won it' been
hilarious
but well that's what oh by by the way
that was interesting because to see Mel
Gibson kind of not only is he a back but
I was talking to uh Frank gillow Mel
Gibson is like everybody wants him to
make their movie because he's so good
but but dude I'm I'm just saying talk
about second and the third chances when
you have an anti-semitic rant on that
level and then you're recorded using the
n-word and talking to your drunk girl
your girlfriend when you're drunk I mean
woo I
thought society's forgiving especially
when you're that talented hwood is when
you can make a great movie I feel like
the world in sports everything like
pretty s like if as talented as he is
and he makes a good movies everyone's
like wow we'll deal with it what did
Jimmy mil Gibson doesn't miss but what
did Jimmy Kimmel say didn't he say
something like uh you don't bring you
wouldn't bring people together would you
Mel he said something funny I was like
damn uh I agree with the best
documentary that O.J made in America how
many times has OJ's story been told and
they did just they got so balls deep in
a different spin it was so [__] so
right now I'm watching uh OJ the the
miniseries on FX yeah excellent yeah and
it makes it impossible to even think for
a second he didn't do it like you were
saying I mean it but I want to watch
that documentary I didn't see that well
that documentary you think he did it for
sure too yeah yeah that's not that's not
the one where they're saying he didn't
do it no I'm not saying yeah that one it
just does complet that's the one where
you find it like his dad was gay and he
they talked to his high school friends
and they talk about his high school days
and it just it's crazy it's so well done
it's insane and it's ESPN one a freaking
Oscar think about that because it was 30
for 30 ESPN yep is that crazy man yeah
and then at the then I was I was it was
so much funnier cuz I wasn't paying
attention when they went and La Land for
best movie of the year I was like God
that makes sense it was ridiculously
well done so original and so that's the
youngest I think he's the youngest
director he's the youngest ever to win
but he was so disappointed so when they
go up there and they're doing it and you
see the commotion in the back you're
like what the [__] is going is there
bomb scare or some [__] and then the
they find out and then that dude's just
like the one guy who's I think he's like
co-director co-writers like produc we we
didn't win we didn't win Moonlight won
this isn't a joke this isn't a joke he's
like I am honored to give them the award
hey man that was so awful for you need
to relax somebody gave Warren batty the
wrong freaking poor Warren batty yeah
and he at least he got to explain
himself he didn't even read it it was
fade dway but no but Warren B batty when
he read he he didn't re she go oh come
on he he know he knew something was
wrong cuz they knew previously and he
was like this can't be right so he had
he showed her and she reads it so my
girl goes who the [__] this old guy
Warren B whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
hold on I went Google him Legend no
Google him he makes me look like a turd
with eyes when he was 20 like
25 dime P there's no one who there's no
one who's taken down Mor Tale in the
history of the world dude he is so when
he was young he had sex with everybody
in Hollywood and everybody of all time
yeah his dick must look like a [__]
Lifesaver P it's just multiple colors
and was doing it such a good looking
dude was doing it well into his 60s well
into a 60 by the way my girl goes oh my
God I went you want another one to rub
your tits to late at night look up Clint
Eastwood when he was 25 if Clint
Eastwood was was like now let's say he
was 25 now he'd be on the front cover of
GQ oh yeah uh he Versace uh Paul Newman
Paul Newman yep uh uh Marlon Brando
Eastwood I mean best looking guys on the
planet Clint Eastwood was always that 6
fo three D PC but Warren batty he beats
them all and he beat Paul Newman was a
fashion guy like he took fashion another
level which I love him for that but he
did not look like Warren batty when he
young Paul Newman for a second and take
a look at his eyes he had the blue eyes
ever Clint Eastwood makes him look like
no nobody does that to Paul Newman Paul
Newman no Paul Newman might have been
the in many ways probably the best
looking young man take a look super
young yeah let let's just get ahead and
see I don't see he's not as good as
looking as waren Betty or uh I mean or
clinty swi yeah not at all Now bring up
Warren Betty well you get get a good
picture of our boy there well that's a
good picture by the way by by the way di
peace yeah yeah by the way some shape
but but I I'll give you this look a lot
shorter a lot shorter than Warren B
Warren Betty's good 6'3 Paul Newman's
about 57 B TT y that'll work though in
splendor in the grass it's it started in
a movie called Splender in the grass it
culminated in a movie called shampoo he
plays a hairdresser and he is
unbelievable in that by the way please
understand that Warren batty also wrote
and directed a lot of great he's a great
filmmaker just a a full set of lip a
great full maker a filer I think Clint
would has them both beat though to be
honest I'd agree he is and his son looks
a little like him but not the same his
son now Clint Eastwood again a composer
a jazz composer a writer a director uh
amazing you know I think Clint Eastwood
got some beat look at Clint Eastwood
there with the with the [__] Scruff
all man all man this one
unapologetically male you know here my
uncle Pax had the same side piece oh is
that right had themselves old standoff
really in Oakland California don't say
yep look at him yeah I mean he was all
man another level yeah another level
you're right 6' three you got first of
all you must take into account height
you Paul Newman's greatl looking but
he's still 5'7 when you're 63 you you
just win the game in that sense you know
you know you know Paul Newman's a guy
too who's known for always being
faithful to his girl that was his thing
how crazy was that that's like his thing
that was but in fact it wasn't
it was no no it's not breaking news he
he had trouble in fact it's it's not so
breaking news now there's the ultimate
that that's Marlon Brando and nobody
touches him I
disagree no yeah 100% talking skill no
no both both uh street car Nam desire
there was just no one like him well no
you're talking about skill I'm talk
talking about looks sir I'm talking
about beauty oh no I know I'm talking
there's no there's no look look listen
as an actor there's no there's no uh
debate about about this I need you to
step down for a sec no no no I'm not
talking about artistic I'm I'm talking
about looks [__] F I'm talking
[__] if you're John right now listen to
me no he's goodl looking there yes he is
I'm not better than Clint Eastwood list
listen to me I need you to Young CL eood
hold on I need you to understand
something I'm going to say something I'm
going to tell you the truth you know why
else clinty would beat them cuz Clint
still in shape Marlin Brandon when he
got older looked like pure [__] true
game
set hold on Sir as a young man when he
did street car name desire it goes
Marlin
he's he's the best he's goat then you
got I'll give you Clint you got Warren
batty you got Paul Newman but I'll give
you Clint as number number
two [__] my number my number five har
Ford's not bad you know what you know
what you damn have a Hollywood train run
on me like a back Harr up with his shirt
off for a second cuz I got for got
something to say he's got something to
[__] say and I might even give him
when he's younger if you say better clef
I will punch your crook giving him
number
three I got to give him over Paul Newman
I he's 6'2 he's 6'2 you got to take into
account like the oh you know who else
you know who else Sean connory thank you
thank you we know our men thank you we
know our men thank you two snabs hold on
bring up [__] Sean connory right
[__] now he's up there for sure now
listen up everybody when he's when he
was when the guy who'd cast him as James
Bond said he looked like a human Panther
the full set of here he looked like a
human Panther
that's not that's not him but that guy's
good looking that's uh that's uh Joe
Frank J Frank's brother he's a dime
piece is that him this one right here
gety what about him right there with
look at that come on tatt it up a real
[__] man he's a man you give him your
girl out of respect you give him your
girl I will punch him in those sir con
sir Conor cuz he was kned Sir connory I
would like to offer you the services of
my woman he retired yeah was like I'm
good he's older yeah he made he $5,000
for 5 minutes of work on that one movie
I can't remember and he was like you
know what all right let's get off of
Jo you know what country he was from was
he from uh not Ireland I believe it was
from Scotland Scotland it's Scotland
yeah that's right he was from
Scotland live was hilarious by the way
he's a bodybuilder bring him up there
let me let me just get it let me let me
take his body in a little bit yeah right
there nope there's another one he was a
bodybuilder right right up there it
doesn't matter this one right here yeah
right there that looks weird that's a
young sh get that off cuz I don't want
to see that he did that he's a little
too oiled up too shaved why you do that
never show me that picture you're having
a good time why' you bring that up [__]
pick on that one with I'm impressed with
your I'm impressed with your man
knowledge yeah now now and Steve
McQueen's probably number six oh he's
stopped
10 I mean these were real [__] oh you
know you know who you're forgetting God
damn it who of course you're forgetting
Charles Bronson as far as sheer
manliness yeah that's up there for sure
you you bring him up for a second cuz
Sean I mean Charles
Bronson I mean Charles Bronson was a I
guess he was a boxer an acrobat he did a
lot of [__] he hey hey he looks like he
has Down syndrome compared to these guys
[__] you hey you know what you're out
Lan right now that guy that guy would be
bring him up there look at look at the
body please no no no the other one the
other one the other one you son of a
[__] next to it yeah right there like
every f look at the body that guy look
at his forearm come on you got to give
it up you kidding me with that guy his
face is tough his face is manly he dud
not hey he looks like Zan you just
ruined thisan you just ruined this whole
segment come on bro how you going to
bring up that uh uh do me a favor and
bring up Nick NTI when he was young Nick
was good when he was young he was all
right but but the body on the body on on
uh no no there's no argument that guy
looks like [__] he looks like every
Mexican dad I've ever seen Charles is
number I'm giving Charles Bronson
number seven oh he's on my top 50 he
looks like Josh hartnet a little bit
here little bit there yeah yeah yeah
then he looks like a straight Navajo
Indian on the left there very WEA well
he I believe he had some Native American
I bet he does no I think he was
Hungarian
Hungarian does look a little bit like
Stitch he had a checkered pass
too I like what people said he had a bit
of a checkered P checkered past it is
weird yeah we got balls deep there into
just dime pieces of old Hollywood we
sure did I know my men you know your men
I'm impressed thanks man you're very
very good you got you hit me with a
couple of names that I didn't think you
were going to get you wer ready I
thought Sean connory at 30 you hit me
with that not bad not bad at all and I
think all of them with the exception of
U Clint Ewood had full mouths they had
the Sha mouth yeah they did Paul Newman
makes a mean salad dressing too makes a
mean salad dressing I believe took no
money from that and G he died they he
took no money from his salad dressing
right did he die back
yeah how about when they were doing
thexton yeah how about when they're
doing all the people who died this is my
problem with that they don't show enough
Clips they skim by it it's like oh Jesus
man they're on to the next one and then
some of the pictures is there any way we
can send our best picture of our family
member who died it was like casting
director and she's all yeah it's like
director all but you know they're just
the worst pictures
there was one that they actually made a
mistake a girl that's living and that
worked with another girl and they put
her picture up so she was freaking out
that sus dude I love that I love that
add Bill Paxton into that I know he died
at like 3 o' in the show because they
they because they do I know but she
could have got there went I in rest in
peace Bill Paxton thank or or end it
with a big picture of him right that's
what I'm saying like I know they
probably didn't have time to put that up
but Sarah baselli is that her name could
have went and rest in peace d beloved
Bill Pax dude it was a shock because I
know people uh our friends the Weavers
are really good friends with him and the
people really love that guy by the way
think about all the movies he did think
about how funny he was and how good he
was in every movie every he he was in so
many big movies he was only 61 61 dude
he went in for heart surgery and there's
complications he died from that yeah how
much of a bummer is that man little
stroke yeah had stroke in the hospital I
guess so and then died cuz they I know
he went in for heart surgery right and
had a [__] 61 is simply too young
it's 11 years for you 11 years I got 11
it's not that long no it's not 11 years
is working think about 11 years ago give
me a movie that happened 11 years ago
chin Avatar Avatar was 11 years ago
Avatar I think it was 2002 that's
ridiculous damn I can't believe it was
11 years ago are you [__] kidding me
look it up that seems like
yesterday first 3D movie wow if that I'm
gonna freak out holy [__] I'm I'm
depressed why that came to my mind I
have no idea that's very good 2009 sorry
still a long time I apologize for it's
still actually 2009 2002 20092 do uh
what about Billy Madison that might be
1999 no that's that's I think it's in
the 90s too yeah that's
19995 holy [__] I'm getting old I know
that's what happens well you know how I
felt when I W I saw Warren batty and he
looked so old and I looked at all the
people like even Hugh Grant there was a
clip of Hugh Grant and I went another
one another one add him to the top 10
you got to add him nah bring the Brad on
a you got to bring a brad on like that
that guy was very good-looking but he's
gotten old and I went that means I'm
getting old have you ever seen like
someone who's in the public uh Spotlight
and you don't see him for a while then
they come back like what corre what
happened correct you know what I'm glad
you brought this up you know I have a
bone to pick with I and I I celebrate
his
music maybe it's an Australian thing if
Keith Urban doesn't stop wearing
foundation and putting highlights in his
hair I'm going to bust but not a cool
way I'm going to bust my fist on your
face so so glad I'm so glad you brought
this up cuz mad at him why does he do
that because why is there foundation on
his face I'll say this he might be very
talented never allowed to hang out never
allowed to hang out on our group because
you're to Vain well no he'll play the
guitar and suck our dick that's the vibe
I get when you have Foundation like that
and then he has these highlights I maybe
again and I love our Australian fans you
guys tell me is that cool out there
right now cuz here you're going get
roasted you might as well walk in listen
to Limp Biscuit and [__] what and an
Affliction shirt why sir why do you have
highlights in your hair you little
perfectly done and then he has
Foundation I'm like yeah I didn't know
he had Foundation Nicole Kidman shout
out Nicole Kidman she's had so many
faceless her ears are back
here does anyone else notice this no I
do notice it it's literally like her
ears like they're like oh babe there's a
Simon coming she's like this yeah I knew
her it looks like she's getting arrested
I knew one of make one of our makeup
artists and it's strange but they're
still doing the damn thing still doing
the damn damn thing they look like
swingers uh no no I like your I like
where your heads at I do like where your
heads at and I and I'm loving that you
went bad on Keith Urban because I'm I
like his music if you had brought up
after the show I would have been like
damn it we should have talked about it
because very talented I guess I I
haven't heard much of his music insanely
talented insane but he takes a he takes
a straight iron under that hair and he
spends a good hour and a half getting
ready he has his own makeup now that you
told me that he has Foundation which I
didn't know and now now you can't you
can't hang out with me when you got
Foundation I feel like they would see me
in the corner like what do you think all
right we're just feeling it out what do
you think about coming in the back with
us after this and [__] both of us
like if well you know what you do have
those highlights in your hair you have
foundation on put some lipstick on maybe
yeah yeah is it weird yeah and because
he's sensitive he's sensitive s
if we were in jail I would say this I'd
say Keith got good news you got bad news
good news you're hanging out with us
when we're all friends the bad news is
need you to get some tape I don't know
where you're going to find the tape need
you to take your balls and I need you to
really tape them right up against your
tummy I want you to pull your balls up
on on and I want them touching and
mashed against your pubic bone here's
why CU when I'm banging you like the
girl you are from behind I don't want to
see your balls ball C problem God forbid
my balls bang against your balls can't
have it I'm going to have a big problem
cuz that's called a boner kill right
it's called a boner kill so so Bren and
I would like you to take a minute tape
your tape your threepiece set up to your
pubic bone use a shoelace whatever you
got to do whatever you got to doel get
that thing tight I don't want to see any
skin now but leave the foundation on cuz
that makes you seem very girly also
don't change your hair leave those
highlights in it and also I like the
extensions well while I'm taking you I
want you to run your fingers through
your hair I want you to run your fingers
to your hair and I want you to say
something girly like I got to get my
hair reh highlighted yes okay and I want
you to say it in a little bit sing it
don't up my makeup don't M make busting
on your stupid face don't as I'm
kangarooing on your stupid face okay
that's an Australian term as I'm putting
a shrimp on the barbie on those
highlights I don't know that's as I'm
taking my Outback Steakhouse C don't get
so aggressive you you can't get you're a
big guy be nice to him he's sensitive
otherwise you'll kill the song bird all
right don't don't talking about the
Australian song bird of Our Generation
so we we want him happy we want him
sensitive we want him to sing for us
I'll fix your makeup when we're done yep
now it's getting a little messy now you
got a list of chores got to clean got to
clean clean up the old pipes now now let
me add yeah you got to clean the pipes
got to clean the pipes the old man first
then the old young buck here after then
you got to clean pip and cook me up a
stew he cook me up a stew it's a hair
he's hairless oh he looks like you he's
hairless too he's got a speedo
on goodl looking dude yeah he's a
good-looking kid and apparently talented
as hell he's got some problems with
alcohol I guess he have like drug
problems before oh maybe that's why he
has the highlights and
[__] um big family might be a great guy
we might be way off and he's just
killing the game I'm sure we'd love him
if he was here but I'm just saying that
if you're in jail and you got all that
makeup on you have to tie that
three-piece set while we go you got to
tie it up yeah yeah while we while we
King your [__] can you not say
kangaroo though why I'm not comfortable
with that I just not really yeah I'm not
okay what about when I think of
Australia let me think okay can we not
what if we put another shrimp on your
Barbie no this is what we say hey bro
tape your stuff up because we're about
to go down land down to the land down
under and here's a big old great white
there's a yeah it's going to feel like a
great white parked his himself up in the
old in [__] we got to get deep but
listen this kangaroo tail in your
mouth don't they don't have tails
kangaroos they yeah they do huge Tails
huge hug Tails that's right that's the
refence but you're getting me all
confused now and you're [__] me up he
you mind if me and the old man here fit
our kangaroo tails in your mouth old man
it's so gross cuz it's just with him
just say Peter Pan or something don't
say old man hey the old man hey you mind
if me and Peter Pan here fit our
kangaroo tails in your mouth and
backside can you not say kangaroo tails
and don't be so graphic just say this
listen
we got he and I we got some we got our
pipes are clogged up a little bit all
right you know how it goes when you're a
guy we've been sharing this [__] jail
cell with you for the past three days
you still smell nice you got nice skin
you're wearing Foundation you know what
that comes with responsibility that's
all now get your guitar out take your
pants off get your guitar out get the
tape out and get you get your pants down
right we'd be nice it's like the tour
bus that's all it is he's a sweetie he's
a sweetie that got weird it got weird it
always does it always does and uh about
brought wait go back Foundation let's go
back to uh I I agree though I think
there's something about vanity in men
when they get to an age like if you're
in your 20s it's it's something cool but
when you're in your 40s I don't know if
you can still wear be that you know
makeup because we know what's around the
corner we know that age gets all of us
and you got to start letting go a little
bit of well I don't mind taking care of
yourself no of course highlight it's
just not it's tough man and it's here
it's it's just yeah well I think people
get caught get attached to what they
used to be like they remember when they
were sexy that's hard to let go cuz
girls love for old guy well girls love
oh he can get anybody he wants
especially when he sings I mean
apparently I've had people tell me he's
insanely talented Keith Iran's huge but
you want to hold on to it yeah he's
amazing his guitar is amazing too he
plays really good guitar oh that's if he
was on this podcast we'd be kissing his
ass oh my God I would show up with
highlights in my hair and foundation
with a shitty tribal tattoo like he has
M yeah he makes us feel bad about
ourselves for security on your tour bus
um but uh oh I know I was me Sting
singing the uh uh the song for is it D
not Daniel Pearl uh Chris the guy who uh
the journal who got captured by uh
alqaeda and got his head cut off great
documentary and they had uh sting write
the song for it he he per performed it
last night it was almost up for it was
up for an award but they didn't win um I
was a julan on this note uh having
breakfast with Jimmy and there was this
really adorable kid whose name was Finn
I go my son's name is Finn that's
awesome and talking and it was kind of a
table for four kids and a a mother a
wife and and a grandmother and a and a
young man and she said uh well he's home
my son my husband's a musician and he's
home for the day the kids are all over I
go oh wow what's he play this oh he
plays guitar James FY she goes and she
goes he's on tour with his dad and I go
well who's his dad she goes sting and I
looked at the guy looked exactly like
Sting I was like well good man pretty
cool yeah so uh it was for yeah that uh
Jim or James Foley if you haven't seen
that Doc it's so good that James Foley
was such a badass because they were
captured by Al-Qaeda I talked a little
bit about it before on the podcast where
they're they get captured and there's
like eight of them and he was the one
like the strength like held everyone
together they were there forever wow and
like oh that's right people like got out
and he like don't worry I'll see you
guys later and then Y and they did they
brought him out for a lot of mock
executions as well all the time I'm
sorry to I'm sorry to make this
right-and turn uh because I don't want
to get too serious because I I talked
about to you about this in the car
speaking of documentaries and I know you
you're a fan of Vice yeah I don't know
if you saw my buddy Joel sent me uh um
this I'll never be the same on Vice yeah
it's on Vice they did a segment uh uh
did you see the donkey [__] segment
is this was this on HBO's Vice or vice
land so there's Vice on
HB I believe it was on HBO's Vice I have
it on my phone here I can show it to you
well chin can bring it up so people see
it in Colombia in Colombia there's an
area of the Northwest I believe of
Colombia where uh donkey [__] is what
you do because things are conservative
and you don't get to have sex until
you're a girl is you marry the woman
here's the thing um the women there are
all the most beautiful in the world so
guys are walking around with blue balls
there's also a lot of Mythology that
[__] a donkey makes your dick longer
so it'll be encouraged that be true I
didn't know that you did some dony I did
my own research they did a they went to
a I looked it into it right and your
dick your dick no I just did I same
place you your research I did my
research all right all right well could
be complete [__] apparently no well
listen apparently not only is it I
watched this not only is it very common
but they showed it they showed a guy
doing it oh no that's not it I hope I
don't want to I want to play it no no
they showed a guy doing it he was
[__] the donkey because they wanted
to see and he goes he walks in he goes
he he goes okay and he turns back around
he goes well I've seen everything now
I've actually seen everything now and I
can't unsee it so I'll never be the same
do they show it on the do they show the
guy B yeah they have it blurred like but
you can see face and he's taking it why
do you this and what's amazing is the
donkey is just hanging out donkey is
just like well I'm getting my my cooch
wrecked well and he's just sitting there
and the donkey's you know you can kind
of stand and are the guys talking about
it like are the guys like yeah this what
we do they admit it what do they say
they all say it's kind of like a write a
passage it's what gets you ready for a
woman it makes your dick longer this all
there and the bottom line is they went
and spoke to the sex therapist who
basically there it is there he is donkey
uhhuh it is a cute donkey and that's the
guy who who basically said
um that this this sex therapist said uh
and she specialized in beastiology and
zilia and essentially that if you think
people haven't been [__] animals
forever you're sadly mistaken because is
anyone arguing that I wouldn't no this
is new right I mean when you're a
Shepherd in the middle of nowhere with
your sheep you got that sheep with a
warm mouth and well the big old
eyelashes I'm just saying those big old
eyelashes late at night yeah right you
wake up that morning boner yeah you
you're gonna take it to your
sheep it's so weird I would rather I'm
sorry this guys would talk about it what
would they say it was just something
that um I actually have some thoughts on
this it was actually something that in
that culture was considered to be sort
of uh what you do when you're 14 15 and
you can't get laid problem is there are
people that would do it who are in their
20s yeah and they keep doing it Cheeto
fingers at 30 still doing it and
essentially for them there was like it's
just it's basically like jerking off
like is that why you natural is that why
yeah but here's what's interesting about
that I actually had a thought I don't
have any doubt on this or anything but
if you if you look at like for example
one of the things in the Old Testament
the Israelites were punished for as they
they got together with I believe the
Canaanites and there was a sect a
religious sect that would have sex in
the temple like in their their religion
the priests had to purify and they would
have sex with all the
they have sex with all the young girls
and it was a it was a sexual cult so in
the way you would worship is you'd have
sex well you know how that goes you got
a bunch of older dudes who are like Hey
listen we got to [__] all the young
girls because we got to pray to God so
what happens was in the Old Testament of
course you'd have a prophet who would
come in and say um this is wrong and if
you guys don't stop it I just talked to
God he's going to send the Babylonians
and the Assyrians you guys are all going
to get killed and sold into slavery and
that's literally
Mr no fun well Mr no fun is right but I
thought about this guess who stops that
kind of behavior in most societies cuz
you know how guys are guys will [__]
anything including the animals around
you no guys I know well no but we don't
grow up in a rural setting with no
access to women yeah we do know through
history that typically when men in
strict cultures they [__] each other
they'll [__] each other they'll [__]
animals this is what happens the bus
loads on butterflies and there there's a
lot of documentary that'll kill the
butterfly I I and
OT no and they don't maybe they do maybe
guys try to come on certain things I'm
sure they I've never tried to aim come
but listen to me I'm G to ask a
butterfly they die I don't want to talk
about that what if you could follow my
my thought here oh God sorry the church
comes in and they because a lot of
people say hey whatever we're just
[__] it's not hurting anybody it's
true probably not problem is that you
have to have some standards some you
have to have standards you have to have
some standards of decency right that's
why you're not allowed to [__] animals
but I believe that's where the church
usually will come in and say hey hey no
I don't care how horny you are [__]
no shouldn't their friends tell this
though or family you need an authority
where's the father figes here but you
need an authority because the authority
can't just come in and say you can't do
that and you'll go why and they go well
because it's this that and the other
thing but the church the church always
came the church have to tell you that's
wrong well they did they kind of [__]
they did the church would come in and
say Hey you [__] are not allowed to
[__] your sheep because it's a it's a
sin now did a little research on that I
don't know if you know where G goria and
where CIS they believe where where uh
what's it called epidemiologists who
studied the origins of disease ganaria
and syphus and especially syphus you
didn't want to get that because you
would go crazy and it was fatal uh if
you don't take penicillin but syphilis
and garia they believe came from yep
they believe it came from sheep and
cattle now part of it might have been
they were eating the Sheep C roasted so
bad if this isn't true I looked it up
okay part of it could be that it was
from you know because the way the HIV
virus thought AIDS came from monkeys
came from monkeys now that that may have
come from eating the monkey the monkey's
brains it may have come from whatever
they the Radio Lab did an a really
interesting sort of thing on patient
zero of this but it could also have come
from [__] your cattle
back in the day so isn't it interesting
that the church always had certain
standards sexual behavior standards uh
not just the church but the temple but
the but the mosque uh basically saying
there are certain standards to your
behavior sexually that we will allow or
not allowed and if you actually follow
it back there was probably a good
scientific reason for it you can't [__]
animals now I know I know it feels good
to bang your donkey but there you do it
why because we said so got to say that
also get a girlfriend a or save your
money and pay for a good oldfashioned
prostitute or yep yep or just wank it in
a corner but hey you can't [__] your
donkeys do we all agree that that's
probably not a good idea I don't know
their options up there chin let's go to
current events you're very liberal hey
man that's their thing you're super
liberal it's so funny that you guys
mentioned kangaroos cuz I had this
loaded up it's marsupio that they caught
on camera
I guess it's it's all over the place in
Australia I've never heard about this
Mar but yeah caught him like jump
leaping towards him to give him a hug on
his GoPro God is that a quala bear it's
called a
Koka well that thing looks like it's
attacking him yeah but then look you
could see down here that they're just
chilling that thing is cute as [__] that
thing's sick I want that bad we need one
as a team mascot okay looks like a giant
rat from the side does look a giant rat
that tail throws me off but he's cute as
[__] like that picture is crazy it's
amazing he's like yeah look at those
claws on him though yeah he's so cool
he's cool as [__] that's in Australia MH
a lot of Crocs a lot of poison snakes we
need to go down Australia man we get out
all the time we should go down there I
would go there gotta fly first class
can't take that trip that long yeah I
agree it's expensive I think the ticket
for first class is like $50,000 a
million dollars I don't know what it is
we should figure out though and get our
asses down there I'll do that I'll do it
Dar in England's where we need to go
uh can I just before we get into current
events did you not feel that my comment
on how art brings people together
throughout all cultures you see I heard
it you don't feel that no I agree oh no
I agree I felt like you were being a
were you bored with t and setting yeah
no I just feel like that was it like the
the messages were so serious and and
it's good after one person does it when
they keep doing it and keep doing oh you
ham home yeah I think every speech when
they're trying to change the world in
the speech
you know same with when you know
football players or basketballers get on
there and they make these crazy speeches
oh the only thing I think the only thing
I think about about Hollywood though
that was interesting is that when
Hollywood gets a bone and like they'll
start you like if Hollywood decides to
start tugging at your emotional
heartstrings and start you know what I
mean they can do it BR together this is
the other problem though if you win an
award and you get up and do that I'm
like oh [__] well I just can't thank my
family and friends now oh that's a cool
thing to do well now I'm going to jump
on board that train like are you you
really mean that or you just doing it
because the rest of the cool kids are
doing it that's that's Hollywood copy
how about the the fact that when they
when they didn't win when LA and got up
there at least they got to thank
everybody it's kind of cool the one guy
saying go we didn't win though I just no
he said no did you see him he goes when
they said come up he goes no because he
knew and then he goes ah [__] it I'll
just thank everybody anyway we lost so
it doesen yeah it was funny all right
what this is a sad one kind of but we
don't have enough information on it but
we saw this what Yer last week once you
found it out Brendon that that Terry
Edam he was apparently trying to throw
himself in front of a bus but all the
articles I read now it says like he was
just sort of running into the street the
cars weren't really moving and he was
trying to smash his head yeah he was
running into park cars right and one was
a parked bus he must have [__] it up
you see the picture of the bus and he's
in critical condition he he critical uh
what's this say I just I just saw
hospitalized ah but does it say why like
but he got in a dis disagre right that's
why it's still an investigation have to
figure out what's going on but his
friends were trying to chase him so it
seems I mean if I was just going to
guess he probably got drunk and got
pissed off and and then started doing
this it's a and he won his last fight in
belor I thought this would be like a a
story where he just lost all his fights
and then you know the brain damage think
May who knows maybe he thought like
something was wrong with his brain yeah
you know he's famous for that wheel K
that's what sucks he's been a tough you
know he's a good Fighter um a b man I
hope he's okay yeah but I wonder what
was going on yeah there's the details
are kind of oh man I mean everyone's
obviously quick to be like oh CT brain
trauma I you know I can't it's same
thing whenever they shooting oh uh brain
disease you know he's mentally ill it we
let's see the facts first you don't know
you don't know yeah my guess would be
people have never fought in their life
too you know drunk and just freaking out
and who knows yeah maybe think I'm sure
it's has more less to do with fighting
more with personal issues sure maybe
he's just depressed maybe you know I
agree what else you got Jen um this one
is interesting did you see the story
about the transer I'm glad you brought
this I haven't seen it please explain
this is actually a girl a high school
girl who's going through the process of
using no taking testosterone to change
into a boy and then she's because of the
rules in that school
your birth certificate if you're a girl
on your birth certificate then you have
to be in girls you know sports sports
yeah and if you're a guy you're in guy
Sports so she has no choice I'm sorry he
has no choice but to wrestle
girls because 56 and0 yeah's beating
everybody see but CU it's a woman I know
what's going on it's a woman taking
testosterone and it's not her she
actually she wants to compete with the
boys but the only way she can he can
wrestle is with the
girls it's more of a flaw in the system
than you know you can be as mad as you
want as at him but he's like [__] man if
I want to wrestle I this is all I can do
I I don't I I still think it's uh I
still think it's a female on
testosterone at this stage at 17 years
old it's a female taking testosterone
competing with other females and that
makes it very difficult for The Other
Women to compete so my opinion in my
opinion I I I don't think be allowed I
don't think she'd be allowed to what
should she be allowed to do not at all
unfortunately if you are going to again
it goes back to personal responsibility
unfortunately if this is something you
want to do if you want to be transgender
and by the way I I have very at 17 years
old I I really think we should be
waiting a little while I'm sure that she
feels but I just where brains aren't
fully developed we don't know at least
to I think 25 there you go I agree with
you um or 21 but um even think about
when you're 21 yeah but this gender
Mania you have a whole support system
now where the kid's 14 and feels
let's let's let's encourage her to do
that so in my opinion um I you lose the
right to compete if you're taking I
think you have to have a standard that
way if you are going to if you are going
to decide to become a a boy that we all
know comes with a set of
responsibilities it comes with a great
deal of baggage it's going to be
difficult for you and it's not and and
and so there is so one of the things L
our job as people is to to and you and I
would be very careful not to ridicule
this person we try to support them easy
solution this you're going on and on an
easy doesn't mean that you can wrestle
if you choose to take testosterone no
but she should she should be with the
boys she should 100% be able to wrestle
with the boys yeah here's the other how
you solve it but here's the problem with
that so the state has a policy which is
to say that it must match it your gender
on your birth certificate has to match
the sport you play because you can do
the reverse now right yeah but how long
ago did they make those rules like we're
living in a different time now I'm
saying so you you got at least
acknowledge a transgender community and
also okay so it has to match female to
male trust me you're not going to have a
huge influx of females who are actual
females trying to wrestle with the men
that's never going to happen but if you
had a if you have a so you're going off
the exception now what they're trying to
do is also if you have a boy and now
he's trying to become a female taking
estrogen but he still has the chromosome
for a man
a bone
structure now he competes with women
it's also an unfair Advantage so in my
opinion when this is not doesn't have to
be we don't have to be politically
correct about it I think that if you're
going to choose to be transgender right
to compete Sports you you have to take
the responsibility that it sometimes
it's just you're going to have an unfair
advantage and and I don't think it's a
fair do but but he won't have an unfair
Advantage boys in the boys there's no
Advantage it's a disadvantage the only
Advantage is when a boy goes to female
the only thing is when you make laws
like when the state has certain rules
you kind of have to blank it I but when
did how long do they make that law not
they weren't even thinking about
transgender what I'm trying to say
though is if you if you if it doesn't if
it if your sex doesn't match your birth
certificate right I mean where it
doesn't matter where you can choose you
would have an unfair Advantage as a boy
going into women's sports no I get it B
but don't you think they have to do Case
by case because um I don't think it's
fair to say it's hard to go Case by case
is it though because not when you have
laws because when you have laws going
Case by case would would create exactly
this you'd have you you can't you
actually can't pass uh case- by case
laws that way you have to have objective
law no I hear you brother but then so
she just by saying all right you
actually feel like a a female or you
feel like a boy trapped in a female body
sorry you don't get to compete in any
sports now unfortunately who's that fair
to it's well it's it's it comes with the
territory I I would suggest I would
suggest I would suggest that if you're
going to make this Choice it's going to
come with a lot of baggage we know that
and so but that doesn't mean they can't
they take away their rights well what
you're doing is you're making it unfair
for all those other women to wrestle
you're making it unfair for all those
other competitive systems make it unfair
because she doesn't want to compete
against other girls she wants to compete
with the boys I understand that I bet
you she doesn't win a match against I
understand but what I'm saying is that
if you you have to be consistent with
the law I'm saying they need to change
the law figure things out because when
they made that law the there wasn't such
an easy route to be transgender
transgender people didn't have a voice
the gay lesbian by uh transgender
Community didn't have as much uh Power
voice as they do now it's a different
time now so you have to acknowledge that
and just can't say oh you're switching
sorry comes territory can't play anymore
the [__] I feel this way though you you
can because otherwise otherwise you're
being unfair to all the other
competitors you you just can't have I
know you're saying Case by case uh
you're saying Case by case one person's
decision to be transgender is not cannot
infringe upon the rights of the greater
let's take every let's take every they
deserve to be protected which you're not
doing let's take every female
transgender who wants to be a male yeah
and do you think they're going to have
any advantage in any male Sports no but
the opposite will be the case yes so the
opposite you're going have to figure out
M so you're just say wellys to F have
such an advantage female have to take
that into account it wouldn't be fair
you know that Muay that Muay Tha fighter
or whatever I mean there are certain
there are certain examples where MMA
fighter whatever it is there are certain
examples where different depending on
the sport where you you you know I don't
think I just don't believe that your
decision to go uh male or female trumps
and and should should allow you to be 6
and0 or whatever it might be in in a
sport I don't think it's fair and I
think that we asking everybody back
they're agreeing with you she's going
she's going I don't want to compete with
the women I put me in the boys I know I
what I keep saying though is that when
you have if you reverse it if you have a
man who decides to be a female and now
compete in female sports he's going to
have a natural Advantage typically
depending on the sport you have to take
that into account and what I'm saying is
that if you choose we all already know
this if if you choose to go transgender
and you choose to change your gender
you're going to deal with a lot of
different issues a lot and obviously
I've always been a guy who says uh
culture is interesting when you protect
your sexual minorities you protect
people who think and act differently I
believe in all that but it doesn't mean
that you uh create an unfair playing
field and I don't think that we have to
change everything and bend over
backwards for one person regardless of
what they choose it's not one person
it's one gender
you're talking about a whole you're
talking about a whole kind of community
I know I know that so so they should not
so if you so you're down with if they
decide to go from female to male there's
no more sports for you ever I'm sorry
they can't play any sports that just
comes with the consequences I don't know
I don't know about that man I'm not
ready to say any sports at all I'm
saying I'm look I'm looking at this as
an example and uh for me I think it's
unfair and I think it would be unfair I
think it's unfair to the other
competitors when you're taking testost
regardless of whether she wants to play
with boys and it's very unfair if you're
a man chooses to be become a woman and
you're taking estrogen but you already
have an advantage in size and bone
structure and you're playing in a sport
you win a bunch of stuff male to female
is tricky male to female is tricky
because men are bigger obviously more
athletic if you want to argue that
please let's do it but also feel but
from a female going to men she's at such
a disadvantage he's at such a
disadvantage with the female bone
structure the testosterone everything it
goes back let's let's extrapolate for a
second go but I don't think you can go
well that's part of it I think you have
to people are smarter than this who deal
with it on day-to-day basis needs to get
together with the transgender community
and figure out a plan that works for
everyone because you can't just go part
of the part of the issue man transgender
Community is pretty from what I have
read and and I and what I've heard when
I've heard these people debate this
they're not a lot of them are um I don't
want to be unfair here but the ones that
I've heard who are the voices of this
tend to be pretty inflexible about this
and uh gender is a choice and it's not
and they try to take biology out of the
choice and that's been a huge issue but
let me extrapolate how do you feel about
this um when a lot of states have you
can use a bathroom that correlates with
the gender of your birth different
animal brother why why because you're
right you have to be consistent let me
tell you why have to be cons but there
has to be some exception when it comes
to sports you can't take away the rights
like they're still going to be able to
go to the basket have to write a law
that but they're still going to be able
to go to the bathroom now they're not
going to be able to compete in sports in
high school no what about so what I'm
saying is so you think so say say so
because really at Heart of it is this
the the law has to be when you're
writing the law you have to say the the
way the way it has to Federal the way
the way Obama administration you decide
that you're a female that way you can if
you decide and you feel like a female
regardless of even hormones you can use
a female clroom that's stupid but we but
but that's part of the law I know but I
get that and there's a terrible there's
laws that are terrible and we know this
I think that if you're a transgender and
you've had the surgery and you're on so
let's say Brendan me I want to become a
female and I go I'm GNA start wearing a
wig start wearing a dress I'm not
allowed in the women's bathroom now down
the road I get rid of my penis I have
tits I've done the correct procedures
where I'm fully in I deserve the right
to go to the women's bathroom
um uh I think if you have a I think I
don't care how you feel if you have a
dick you should not be allowed in the
women's
bathroom I think you have to make that
major step to the next level to deserve
that right and I'll take heat about that
and I would agree with you on that and
the transgender Community would totally
disagree with you on that and I agree
with you that I know maybe and maybe
because like Caitlyn Jenner talks about
all all women's rights this but she's a
Republican and she doesn't believe in
gay marriage okay and then you won't cut
off your dick doesn't she still have
yeah still has a dick Woman of the Year
get the [__] out of so let me get this
straight you you're preaching all this
stuff over here but you won't cut you
won't go you feel like a woman but you
won't do most women don't have a dick
and so all women don't have a dick but
but you're scared to cut off why is that
because if you actually felt 100% like a
woman you would cut that thing off that
thing would be Tor I agree with you 100%
so she got woman of the year I guess
that's just for Ratings you know what
I'm saying like either you're all in
then you deserve the rights but if
you're balanced on both you're playing
both sides F you can't play Both Sides
you have to be all in and and I agree
you get all the rights I can just see
people going yeah now you're saying that
how about the woman how about the woman
who who was posing to me posing as a
black woman remember and now she's been
fired she can't get a job she was the
head of the NCAA doing great work for AF
yeah yeah and then and then she's so
white meanwhile um she's now calling
herself trans black and she's saying
that race is fluid as well get the [__]
out of here and this is what happens
when you don't have certain standards
because now we have no way to talk about
any
you do have to have like there is
biology I'm sorry plays a role this is
my this is how we get crazy right crazy
but with this they have to figure some
because it's not right to deny her the
experience of playing High School sports
it's just not because she doesn't have
an advantage she will get probably beat
by every man how about she gets to
compete but it doesn't
count why would it count cuz she's
taking testosterone and playing youing
with the girls yeah that's not fair well
it's also not fair that she's taking
testosterone and beating the [__] out
all these girls she doesn't want to do
that though she's like I don't want to
do but it's the only way it's either
that or nothing I agree with that like
well [__] man wrestling wrestling's my
passion the only way I can wrestle is by
[__] wrestling these girls otherwise
I get I don't get wrestle I said this
hey if you want to wrestle with the
women you have to stay a woman and you
can't take drugs right now that are
making you more male how does that work
there you go here's the [__] solution
okay if you're gonna if you want to
wrestle let's wait till you're out of
high school to start doing this if I'm
the par I'm going I realize that if you
do this you're never going to be allowed
to compete that's fair isn't that fair
that's reasonable why can't you wait are
you going on scholarship to and let wait
let the kid give the kid time for her
brain bra develop when you were 21 are
you are you 21 21 I have tattoos I
[__] hate littleone cut off my dick I
was the biggest idiot on the planet at
25 at at 28 I was a [__] go back and
watch some my UFC highlights go go watch
some my interviews it's true my first
fight I thought I wanted to fight Frank
Mar and Josh
Barnett I'm sure if I was transgender
time I'd say yeah cut off my dick pay
four years later I'm like what the [__]
I know no I don't feel like that anymore
you go through phases we know that the
brain is not fully developed we know the
frontal cortex we know teenagers are way
more impulsive they have different
brains they they're not developed now
I'm not saying some people aren't born
in the wrong body in the wrong wiring I
get that but what if she waited four I'm
with Brian this is a great example if if
she waited four years and got to
experience the high school uh wrestling
experience like all the other kids is
that going to kill her right no and
you're what's more important to you too
there you go that's another life is
choices life is choices she should be
able to do both I get that but the way
the system is you're not going to be
able to do both right life is a great
that's a great idea be y but and also
what's her background like did she was
there sexual trauma that makes her feel
this way what is there drug use involved
was their medication cuz a lot of times
the brain takes it like what your 21's
developing 22 25 25 so it takes a lot of
time to for that brain to develop let's
wait till you're 25 hate to tell you
there's no going back once you cut that
front tail off There's No Going you push
it in don't you I don't think you cut it
off you actually they turn to clus they
cut it and turn into clus slice it for
like like a hot dog like slice like a
hot dog fold it in God Western medicine
I mean West medicine it's brilliant it's
so cool people have the ability to do I
think if you actually feel like that way
it's so cool you can do this now I'm all
for one of those tricky things I mean
that's why like discussions like this
what the fact that this is on like a lot
of different websites it's the beginning
of how to deal with it you can't deny
the experience to play high school
sports so because she feels that you may
have to stop doing test CU where do you
I agree that's probably the best route
to go it sucks you'd have to do that cuz
where do you stop it oh like boys we we
can't have you in the locker room we
can't have on the football team CU you
want a [__] every guy no I don't you
know what I'm saying right I get it's
not the same Advantage you know like
where do you stop if you like your
blanket rule where do you stop right oh
we got lesbian you can't play softball
man you want to [__] all the girls I
mean I could I could give you right now
I mean you're a bad example because
you're trained but I could put I could
pump you so full of estrogen give you
tits take that the balls and dick off
and everything else and I could put you
in WNBA in the in the sh I was gonna say
or or in female wrestling in the
Olympics and I believe you would win a
gold medal in Greco Roman and and all
the events ever you want sir right away
with no problem and I'll pump you I'm
going to get you girled up I mean girl
up I want a full set of Double D's oh my
God you're going to be you're going to
biggest in the world and you're going to
have a I'd just be a you're going to
have a vajin I'd be a 100% but but you
would still you would still have just
give him the gold medal beforehand yeah
just give it to me now cuz that'll Spike
every girl in the face yeah so anyway
maybe estrog I'll do respect the female
wrestlers
uh man might be my favorite female fight
next one you do like her yeah what else
you got we were just talking about it
too the khabib's father was denied
access to get into the states way to go
way to go cuz that guy's a threat yeah
he's a real threat there you go unb
[__] go everybody they didn't mention
if it was thre there's khabib's pants
Jesus Christ I'm making easier for uh
although this this order has been
challenged so what's really going on cuz
people can come in at this point they
said also in Russia that they've been
denied before different from different
people from Russia but I don't know in
this instance cuz I thought this would
had something to do with the the travel
band but it doesn't at
all okay so it says right there Russian
citizens from the north caucuses have
struggled to gain entry into the United
they're not like singling him out dude
the
caucuses
um best match up in the long time in the
UFC this weekend also I'll get balls
deep into big breakdown but needs
everything to you know that [__] with
you and this is the biggest fight of
khabib's career your dad doesn't come in
that would bother the [__] out of me it
would it would it bother the [__] out of
me a guy like khabib's going to make him
more Angry a Russian kabib is going to
make him more Angry you're if I'm Tony
first I'm going [__] for sure let his
dad in like this the last thing I need
100% let his dad through the goddamn
does his dad Corner him or is his dad uh
just there as moral support I don't know
if he's cornered him I know his dad
train trained him when he was younger
his dad was a wrestler yeah he's a huge
influence on his life though he he's his
Idol it's like he's never missed khabib
has brothers too I think they all
trained for train kids and they were you
know I don't know how what else you got
CH then we'll get into some of the
fights okay after I peed out of this
kangaroo tail this one I just saw like
an hour ago you know this guy Bob Harper
from the fat The Biggest Loser not the
fattest loser the fattest he just
suffered a heart attack oh really yeah
uh I don't know him Fitness Guru oh he's
the host yeah the I guess he's gay right
he's I think the gay guy on the show so
so as a 50-year-old U my doctor said um
that he he was running a Sonic Sonic
gave me an EKG but then he ran a Sonic
sound over my chest and stuff and he
said um this is when your friends will
drop dead between um 45 and 55 it's
called a Widowmaker where you can have a
compromise in your artery and not know
it and just die my friend's uh husband
died
might I don't know dude my my uh klopp
he's coming in town oh you're going to
be out of town he comes in town Thursday
for my first show but he's getting here
his aunt's husband was big time dude
lived in Burbank ran this company I told
you the story he would ride his bike to
work every day and he had something a
little bit wrong with his ticker he'd
ride his bike every healthy as [__] rode
it all over to and from work was like 20
miles he'd go there and he had a shower
in his office that overlooked the
Burbank he'd go up there and he take a
cold shower went up there took a cold
shower and they said something [__]
the system died on the spot thre a
clot my uh my buddy uh was in the
hospital and almost died recently young
guy and now he's fine but his body just
started throwing scar his liver you you
just got to stay on top of him man stuff
is scary like the guy too the fighter I
think it was a kickboxer remember he
he's been in a whole bunch of different
fights but he was just riding his
bicycle like a regular bicycle and got a
heart attack and died yeah it's widower
you have well so did uh the track star
the girl track star remember her uh
Jackie Joiner cury or whatever she died
that way yeah it's not her name but
something like that jaie try I think
that is her name so what's up with this
this homeboy I remember this guy from
Biggest Loser yeah so he had a heart
attack he just had a heart attack and
he now that the news say was from two
days ago he just he just got released
from the hospital God man so SC yeah man
you don't want that so someone him like
he's training people all the time you
know they do rigorous training on that
show too yeah and he get no but that's a
compromise so that your heart can just
have a blockage this is the other thing
and I'm not saying he is I'm not trying
to any rumors but he's shredded all the
time it's very hard unless it's a
genetic thing but I'm I think was he big
before and he got skinny I don't know
but a lot of time they're on a lot of
supplement supplements so it could be
high blood pressure oh that's
interesting there's there's a lot maybe
he's taking fat loss stuff maybe he's on
a weird diet where you know it's a
really maybe he's a ketogenic he's on a
shitload of fats and his body doesn't
agree with it or there's certain things
one thing they know that when you do
testosterone for example you have to be
very careful because your lipid levels
your blood pressure can go Sky High
that'swe skin changes color a lot of
times yep his mom died from a heart
attack there you go it's genetic too
genetic so that's probably has something
to do with it wow what else you got that
sucks man what else you got get your
heart checked I think a lot of it's
fight stuff which I'm that's all good I
got to PE so hard go for it
I guess a woman was arrested on
suspicion of setting up to 28 fires in
Fullerton with her name is UN Esther cha
24 how did she get away with 28 she
looks very sweet very normal and she's
clearly an arsonist which means she gets
off on setting fires she's not bad
looking you know what they call that
right that's that's called a pyromaniac
pyromaniac hey chin is that is uncha
what ethnicity is that damn it does
sound Korean I know I didn't want to
sound racist there looks Korean too
isn't it it might be Vietnamese possible
Chaw is like a different name it could
even be Chinese I'm going to go with I'm
going to say she's vietnames chines look
at that picture though she's not bad
looking not bad at all for an arsonist
yeah pyromaniac for a pyromaniac she
ain't bad but make no mistake that that
sweet face is into watching things
burn did she kill what did she set on
fire she set a car on fire some trash
cans uh
I don't know if she should ever be allow
out I know don't be mean to her but let
her Bush no she shouldn't go away for
send bushes and mailbox on fire well you
know what comes next houses and Shing no
she also needs some help she does she
needs a therapist and a and a nice dick
down can you well sure but can you help
somebody who's a pyromaniac cuz she's
not into dick she's into fire on fire
she's into fire your dick is good but
all I'm thinking about is setting she's
clearly single as [__] too know about
what is like what triggers someone to be
an arsonist rather you know so so so the
from what I have so I know a lawyer who
defended for many years a pyromaniac and
the guy would set fires start huge fires
dress up as a fireman and redirect
traffic he'd redirect traffic away from
the fire
no he wanted to be a guy he wanted to be
a fireman who was protecting from the
fire he said and bit of a loser she
sounds like she's a wild one there are
two things that go on apparently with
fire with with arsonists with arsonists
one is uh this where you want to set a
fire and then be a hero in finding the
fire the other though is also part of
what a sociopath will do is to create
insane damage or havoc and sit and watch
people panic and free freak out over the
loss of their property so there's this
there's this there's actually a sexual
gratification of getting off this [__]
just send like trash cans on fire though
I think she just enjoys like send [__]
on fire please remember sir she's not
watching anyone she starting as with all
Mania sir starts there you start small
you remember what do serial killers do
they start by torturing animals yeah and
that's then they graduate to humans
that's right that's right so she goes
from Max apparently it's not enough to
kill the people after a while then got
to eat them got to start eating them got
to start first well there's one step in
between eating and killing what is it
sex nope you got to drink well you have
sex with their bodies when they're dead
y but you also you also drink their
blood MH yeah vampir they just can't
cure their urge like gets worse and
worse and it never goes back apparently
the
theology you can't reset it gets worse
yeah so you know they start wearing
their skin yeah we're dealing with I
don't know how you help a fire hey well
let's start with your mom well she's
only 24 though let's start here I'd like
to have her in here got to change her
brain
well she needs clearly some help like
can can we replace your love for setting
fires on baking yeah maybe with this
dick with this fire starter no no just
baked cookies can we try that can I ask
you a question you know she sets fires
you know she's an pyromaniac you know
she's a mini pyro though she's not she's
not doing things like that you know that
right now listen can I ask you a
question sure if she's hot yeah you bang
her anyway don't you how hot like that I
see the good she's about a seven she's
about a seven she's a seven she's s
fires yeah I'm not going to marry her
but I'll call her over lateer at night
there you go yeah yeah see even though
even though she's a pyromaniac as long
you're not saying my [__] on fire but
you're freaking the sheets yeah you're
not hurting people well she is hurting
probably she's she's way to hurting
people we know she's on her way to
burning [__] down well then I'll then
you know what then I'm a snitch on you
like once you're like listen you know
how I told you I set that fish tank on
fire the other day I'm like yeah she's
like I'm thinking about setting SeaWorld
on fire I'm like all right yeah cool
yeah here here suck this dick uh have a
good night yeah yeah no yeah her name's
was unan and she is uh setting
everything on fire this is where she
lives the only thing that you should say
also is this when you just say you
should say listen uncha just told me
she's going to set a fish tank on fire
which means two things once she's a pyom
also too she's dumb as [__] because fish
tank is mostly water and SeaWorld is
almost all water cuz it's called sea and
you can't set the sea on fire so she's
dumb as [__] so I just wanted you to
know I have
I have no idea it was the worst example
I on record in the 400 [__] episodes
we ever seen that was the worst example
I've ever heard in my life hilarious in
my 50 years fish tank fish tank on fire
huh well no you set the cuz the fish
tanks are on wood so you set the wood on
fire watch the fish boil they made of
glass and then you eat them it's glass
steel and godamn water toat
[__] oh you can't set SeaWorld on fire
it's it's the only thing that's actually
fireproof might be a fish tank for real
yeah the one thing you find after the
fire the house has been burned out is
the fish boiled in [__] this [__] is
a chemist she has a certain kind of
chemical sets the glass on fire that's
how you make glass you can say whatever
you want but I don't think uncha is a
chemist I think she's just a d she's a
dumb as [__] pyromaniac who gets into oh
we saw this one they caught her they
finally caught her but I was looking
about the dick suck dick suck Bandit
remember she had no hair yeah that's
this is what she like with hair give her
a trophy get the [__] out of here full
set of lip I'm not mad
how dare you arrest her for that you
[__] Puritans yeah they got her she's
a good person a good americ what they
going to do give us slap on the wrist
and let her continue second day yeah you
can ruin her career like she can't get a
job when you do this [__] [__] well
she has a a thing where she so many
different times too that was her thing
great I would give her a job right now
she could be my ass Club at a strip club
I got a job for you as my assistant
what's her first name doesn't matter it
was BJ right so I forgot Britney Britney
Jones Britney no it's Britney
Britney
Jonesy that's why I was a crazy you're
telling me you're telling me Magic City
Atlanta shouldn't hire him like come get
your dick sucked by BJ the famous BJ
100% she'd be making bank she would
doing a lot of work but if you enjoy it
if you enjoy it this is my business plan
I will be your manager time to get
sucked hey boys guest who's coming to La
it's BJ Britney Jones you're going to
get a rain and suck now the here's the
tricky part though she has to film and
put on face Facebook so if you're
married probably wear a
mask huh it's true wear a mask always
wear a mask Britney full set of lips a
round face a big chin she will suck your
dick like never before she's got a chin
on her Ladi and gentlemen her hair
really isn't purple either that would be
a wig you [__] she's wearing a wig
she's actually bald this girl can suck
Chrome off a trailer hitch and she's got
wi now please do not Yank on the wig
while she's sucking your dick cuz it
will look like Magic Johnson is sucking
you there you go look at her oh man all
right moving on yeah what else I think
that's it yeah that's probably it you
drop in knowledge I sure do beat the
Oscar one what's that the Oscar
knowledge was good right very good very
good my my knowledge my oscar my my
dropping knowledge is something that's I
was thinking about this and I just want
to give it to you guys like when I was
very critical of Kanye and I did some
research on him I I full yeah I've been
very critical of um Steve Bannon who is
uh Donald Trump's Chief strategist and a
lot of people is actually he's running
most of the his agenda is what Trump is
you know carrying forth whether that's
true or not but he's been painted by the
media as being such the Boogeyman and
I've heard nothing but bad things he he
ran Breitbart News which is pretty far
right and there was so much negative
coverage and I said to my myself you
know I've been buying this let me do my
own research and I looked at Steve
Bannon Steve Bannon was a naval officer
Harvard Business School did a number of
documentaries worked at Goldman Sachs
this guy is a highly accomplished guy he
um is he believes essentially in the
things I believe in a free market in
capitalism in in Freedom and all that
stuff small limited government he's a
little bit too much of a nationalist for
me he tends to be too much too
anti-immigration in general he's like
why do we have to bring anybody in the
country at this point we want let's use
resources for people here I don't agree
with that we're a nation of immigrants
but when what I'm trying to say is that
if you get your information from just
the media you're going to have a very
skewed understanding of who somebody is
and so if you don't like somebody if you
disagree with somebody you you need to
do your own research and here's why if
you want to be a effective and get your
ideas out there and if you want your
ideas to win and if you want to be
somebody who's moving the world forward
you had better know your enemy and you
had better know what you don't like
about them because look here's another
classic example Pew research the Pew
Research Center did a study on Muslims
and they said they they came back with
something about how literally 25% of
Muslims in most countries believe in
Sharia law uh and quote unquote have
extremist views let's examine that for a
second I don't know how many questions
were asked of the average Muslim who
answered these polls but I think let's
call it six
questions you have to ask yourself do
you really think you can know a human
being by asking them six specific
questions over the phone the answer is
no we are all way more complicated so
when you call somebody an [__] or you
say somebody's a [__] or somebody's
a homophobe or a racist please please
take a look at the whole human being
because the whole enchilada look at the
whole enchilada man because they may be
an [__] in one facet of their life
but they may add value in others and
even a guy like Steve Bannon who I was
critical of who I read a lot about from
Mostly liberal media I think they have a
lot of what he has to say wrong I think
they're unfair to him and this is a guy
who doesn't like Trump but I think I
think that the media has done themselves
no [__] favors uh especially the
liberal media because I think they are
very one-sided they replay over and over
what somebody says they only take a very
skewed approach so please do your own
research that doesn't mean go to Alex
Jones and infow Wars but just look at
the other side man take a look at the
other side and uh and don't get all your
information from Google try to read some
[__] books uh I guess I'm 50 and it's
how I feel but if you want to change
things man don't don't look at just one
aspect of a person where do you get your
where do you get your news from bro CNN
yeah you got to get your news everywhere
I did too CNN's not fair no the CNN's
the the TMZ of politics I agree with you
it's so stupid it's just used to be my
favorite man yep get your news from a
lot of different sources and read hold
my hand brenon hold my God dang hand
warm I have a warm hand bro you know
I've been training a lot damn a lot hey
are you are you ready for our photo
shoot tomorrow yeah 2:30 brother yeah
whiten those teeth I got it let's do
some question I'm gonna see the dentist
next week can't this week next week I'm
gone I need I need invisaline got to get
my heart checked and my [__] checked
that's what happens when you're 50 let's
get a camera up
there
colonoscopy
colonoscopy that's F you're supposed to
have it at 50 I got to do it the first
question let's just do like four of
these Jen okay cool this is It's a Long
podcast what time is it I like it I'm
we've been doing two hours
already yeah Eric Young 75 chin how was
driving the Bentley Brendan how freaked
out were you seeing your baby drive off
I'm sure they met your car yeah not my
baby well we already touched on it well
but no
Chin I should put on record that uh
Brendan did give me the opportunity to
drive it for the day but I just took it
around and I got freaked out cuz I
didn't want to have that much
responsibility panicked but then it was
just cool that he actually let me have
it so yeah yeah that D that that D run
you about 20 grand yeah yeah uh I wasn't
too stressed I'm chin you're not a
you're not a sporadic or like wild crazy
guy I went too slow too yeah you could
had some fun at least took it down the
405 um but after seeing what happened in
my
car a couple days yeah I'll probably
chill out on everything I'd let chin
drive it again though hell yeah what
else you got all right Joe mcbaine how
did you guys how come you guys didn't
mention the big di big dick Bandits
anymore that theme song is constantly
stuck in my head many people have asked
me too this I think we should rewrite I
think we should re we need a new one
that was so long ago let's get let's get
uh when Skyler's in here I'm gonna let's
let's let's write some lyrics and let's
have Skylar join in kind of it has come
from you and me that's the cop you and
me need to come do some chorus he come
up n it can't do that it has to come
from you and me all right yeah yeah why
don't we revisit big dick Bandit
why don't we come up with that come up
with a new one the big dick Bandits big
dick Bandits you know how big dick
Bandits come from Brian and I were
playing uh uh beach volleyball mirand
Del re and we were with Will Sasso and
someone goes what's your team name and I
go the big dick Bandits and started
marching up and down the sand that's
right and then we started singing big
dick Bandits big dick Bandits big dick
Bandits big dick
Bandits lock up your daughter you have
that that's not the original what the
lock up your daughter lock up your wife
well I sang it what was the original all
original was big dick Bandits big dick
Bandits big dick Bandits yeah I know
we've gotten away from I just started
singing it out we've got away from
singing yeah we got to bring back some
singing I need more I need more singing
on you less politics all right need more
singing We need more music a little B
yeah all right maybe sing about politics
Donald Trump is
orange what else you got Jen never does
exercise T Brady 155 Brian Ken with the
upcoming Goldberg spin-off are the
writers starting to write in more screen
time for your character to gain more
interest dude before you answer do you
know they they eared your commercial
during uh the Oscars that's what I heard
I didn't see it but I heard was for your
for your for your episode it showed you
uh going let's get it on like the kids
were about to fight or something oh yeah
nice well there you go I guess I was I
was technically in the Oscars this time
this year Brian was part of the Oscars
was part of the Oscars can say that and
not lie [__] Oscar you could like we
when we go to lunch after you could just
be like you know I'm exhausted the whole
world saw my face you I was part of the
Oscars last night pretty crazy man to be
involved and oh you on there I'm pooped
several times yep I'm pooped Ryan goson
then me yep I like it um last one Chen
oh did you answer the question oh what
was it question uh the the writer is
going to write in more stuff for screen
time well the show is basically you know
I'm kind of
the new show and you guys shoot that in
April um I think March middle of March
March soon mid March so a few weeks yep
yeah so
far March 1 is tomorrow yeah Thursday
Wednesday Wednesday Wednesday yeah CU my
Show's oh yeah yeah Wednesday second
freaking
Thursday all right Blake hunsicker
another question for Brian can you
please film paranormal activity in your
house that's a good call and when I was
over your house your wife was telling me
we should do a Paranormal Activity well
we got to have our boy Chad no you and I
should do yes that's right no we need a
legit Paranormal Activity guy him or
Zach now I'm a little nervous about that
can I tell you something else that
happened I can't believe I didn't tell
you this you you and Amanda went shut up
I was taking a shower and my dog ran
into my my closet and then ran out
cowering and sat there and looked at
that closet was anyone in the closet
nope
nope now maybe ghost maybe those Ghost
German Shepherds were waiting and how
about Stevie you stayed at my house and
he goes oh you're he goes oh yeah I'm
glad you brought that up I go what he
goes I don't want to tell you but your
house is definitely haunted and I go
what the [__] are you talking about he
goes bro I'm telling you when I was
sleeping I just heard a bunch of running
upstairs and I had the dog with me and I
there was running upstairs people were
running around upstairs I move out and
he goes ah somebody's up there for sure
went up there checked out went up there
and checked it out nobody there he said
you like matter of fact like this he
goes yeah I didn't want to tell you your
house is definitely haunted it's haunted
I was like well you know I I'm not
moving I would move so it's me and the
ghosts i' move I'm never moving get get
uh get get a priest in there or
something they'll make him go away I
just got to figure out just dogs they
need an outlet I got to figure out how
to live with the with the ghosts it's
all good no no no go exist now just have
someone come up there and uh rectify the
house all right you know what I'm saying
burn Sage yeah yeah yeah they don't like
Sage there's a shitload of them in
Venice I got you know I'll send someone
all right send somebody over I'll get
someone with Venice foot to go on your
house and do it uh they can find you in
Boston this weekend right this this
weekend guys March 2nd 3 4th I am at
laugh Boston get your tickets get your
tickets they're going fast Stevie bluee
Boston kid me and the Boston kids Stevie
blue eyes are bringing heat and then
this Thursday my first oneman show sold
out Ice House Pasadena beautiful excited
for it and then see ran K and myself
April 7th in Philadelphia at the
truckadero and April 8th in Washington
DC very EXC at the 9:30 Club very
excited tk.com for all your needs we got
the hoso we got the skeptical hippo we
have new uh big brown breakdown te's
dropping next week y'all yeah B booy ya
I see you guys complaining that there's
not enough shirts on the store uh it all
be reloaded next week you're welcome
this is the final kid we're out